all right so YouTube and Google have
once again changed their configurations
of the back end of the interface and I'm
checking on how this new YouTube webcam
app actually works since Google Hangouts
are completely gone this is just a test
I'm seeing how you actually get in here
and make things work since well people
are writing stuff so I can actually it's
kind of nice actually I got a usually
when when things roll out I'm not too
happy about it but I can actually see
the chat in the side with the the video
window so for once I don't have to have
two different things open at the same
time yeah so it looks like it's doing
pretty good I had to tinker around with
some settings in order to make sure that
it was on central time because it was
defaulting to like you know Google time
way out west and so yeah people are
saying things look and sound good so
this is just using the camera and the
mic from my laptop if this actually
sounds good enough then I don't have to
get out the big blue mic to use for
other things although I probably will do
the AMA upstairs
in front of the Big Mac so alright so
let's say people are chiming in with
these things yeah this is this is not
actually going to be any sort of talk or
anything I've got a ton of work I got to
do this weekend but while I'm here I may
as well chat a little bit so I'm you
know I'm I'm at the very end of my third
online class and I'm still shooting tons
and tons
video for that it's a business ethics
class and I've shot about a hundred five
to ten minute videos for that class I
got a whole slew of classes coming up in
less than a month two of them online a
number of them face to face and that's
even with turning down teaching
assignments so I'm gonna be one busy guy
but later on this month next Saturday we
got the AMA coming up I got to talks in
the Milwaukee area this week one on
jean-jacques rousseau out at the Frank
Weinberg library in in Mequon and then
August Derleth on Thursday at the
Brookfield Public Library so lot going
on here what else got to start shooting
some new video content for my classes
coming up this this fall so a lot of new
core concept videos out so well I may as
well answer some of these questions so
guy says you're a stoic doesn't suit you
to be sad
actually that's not quite true I think
you need to read more stoic stuff but
I'm not a stoic by the way I you know
I'm an eclectic so there's a whole video
out there like that do I cover Ussuri in
my classes do you mean I mean sometimes
the only if you're talking about the
business ethics yeah you don't you
generally call it Ussuri we can talk
about predatory lending or stuff like
that
let's see here the self-directed
philosophy playlist it's not the
neoplatonist that are coming up next it
is Cicero I mean technically I should do
that the skeptics because I did you know
Plato
Aristotle Stoics epicureanism and
they're like the fifth big school but I
want to get into Cicero in part because
I really like him and I think it could
be useful to have some advice about you
know how to study the guy so that's
that's what I'm doing for this month the
neoplatonist we're gonna get to down the
line before them comes Plutarch in the
middle plate mists and actually I don't
want to spend too much time lingering in
the ancient period because I want to do
those self directed study and philosophy
things for medieval and early modern and
late modern thinkers as well so um let's
see I asked for it from highest society
I don't have a favorite YouTube channel
about philosophy I don't really watch
many other people's videos because I
don't have the time I have a personal
and family life I have heavy teaching
obligations much higher than many other
full-time professors I have my business
on the side or doing tutorials
philosophical counseling speaking I have
my writing projects I've editing for
stoicism today trying to get my own
writing stuff done on side so I don't
really have much time for watching other
people's videos or giannis you've become
old are you scared of death and what do
you think of this topic long story cut
short
yeah I'm middle-aged you know I guess if
you're a young person maybe I appear
very old but I'm I'm actually 48 right
now I'm not scared of death I haven't
been scared of death for quite a long
time I'm more concerned with not getting
done the things that I want to get done
and with frittering away too much time
on things that don't really matter so
you know like I'll give you an example
of something that I particularly care
about and that is sassy right over there
she's gonna be 17 this year which is I
think the equivalent being like
90 year old person I don't know how much
longer I'll get with her but she is one
of the best cats that I've ever had I've
had quite a few so you know I can really
you know do this thing over here this
thing over here this thing over here you
know debate this person or I can spend
time hanging out with this living being
here so alright a lot of people going
back and forth about Rousseau well you
know I'll say this right off the bat to
address those comments any sort of
sweeping assumption about Rousseau is
stupid just plain stupid I mean that's
the way it typically is you know blaming
him for the whole French Revolution you
know saying that he had everything right
I don't know why people want to do that
sort of thing unless they're just sort
of beginning in philosophy and trying
out their little wings
alright Cicero so where to start with
Cicero there is no place to start with
Cicero we've lost the one book that
probably would have been the place to
start the Hortensius right and it's been
gone for a very long time who knows
maybe we'll dig up a copy somewhere but
I'll talk more about that when we do the
video which will be later this this week
cat philosophy that's that's an
interesting idea I'm going to be doing
some if I ever get to it you know I've
got plans to write a book to help people
out with making end-of-life health
decisions and death decisions about
their pets because I and I know from
having gone through that and seeing
other people going through it that it's
quite tough so alright I am going to
wrap this up this is just a test to get
going
checking out this YouTube interface
looks like it works just fine so if you
guys say that the sound quality is
adequate maybe I don't need a special
mic for this couldn't hurt though I
suppose to have it and yeah
people asking all sorts of other
questions and things like that well you
know so carmine says video audio quality
is great what is it one of the rest do
you think about that I mean looking at
the video just on what I can see it's a
lot sharper than it was with Google
Hangouts so I think maybe you know
YouTube somehow came up with a better
product which surprise surprise usually
the tech world thing seems to be getting
simpler and crappier as time goes on but
this this is actually pretty good
I gotta get to much shooting my update
video so thanks for all of your feedback
that's very helpful and we'll see now
the next test is gonna be seeing does
this actually process the way it's
supposed to and feed right into the
YouTube channel if it doesn't then we
got some problems but you know it's
starting to look pretty good so far
alright so Oh Alejandro says about the
half hour Hagel series I'm definitely
gonna get some Hagel videos this month
I've got time blocked out for it so and
I gotta do some writing about that
alright I'm gonna say goodbye to
everybody and thanks for the feedback is
very helpful and be having the update
video for the month coming out a little
bit later today
I gotta go shoot it upstairs in just a
few minutes